this movie was just talk top-notch
professional that the script the words
they said how fat well the actors played
it and the cinematography following them
along through halls I wasn't familiar
with Aaron Sorkin's work because I don't
watch television so this was the first
time I saw it and unbelievable to me and
you actually spoke with Aaron Sorkin
leading into this film tell me about
your role yes yes we had meetings on
multiple occasions and just talk for
hours hours anything I could think of
saying little tiny tiny bits that were
somewhere else kind of got used by him
and painted in a different way a
different place and you spent hours with
him on the phone in person in person in
person oh yes oh you guys argue about
anything did you disagree over any
scenes um no we read fact we haven't
even talked about the scenes I never
once looked at the script after he wrote
it I didn't feel it was appropriate for
somebody in a movie to look at a script
and say no it didn't happen this way
because it's his art and his art isn't
this when you're close to something you
always see a movie every movie I've seen
about Apple they've got all the scenes
people's personalities are wrong this is
not what we said this is not out went
out these are not the things we would
have done and and after a while after a
while you realize well it's the artistic
freedom to make a movie that's enjoyable
because some others have said well
there's a lot of things in this movie
that didn't actually happen I mean would
you say that um maybe everything in the
movie didn't happen but they're all
based on things that did happen every
for example it didn't happen well maybe
but you see everything I say every scene
that I'm in I wasn't talking to Steve
Jobs at those events I don't even say
things like that and I didn't say them
but they were based upon things for
example there's parts of me saying Steve
please please acknowledge the Apple 2
team all the way for 15 years through
the movie like I would do that and all
it's based on is there was one
shareholders meeting didn't mention the
Apple to the people in the Apple 2
division were ready to quit and I don't
complain but on their behalf I was their
only voice so for them I called John
Sculley not Steve Jobs I called John
Sculley to come on so things get rebuilt
into a movie in certain ways there's
also myths about me Steve Jobs our
relationship what we did and those come
out in the movie more along the lines of
the myth and not real so what is the
myth and what is the reality well one of
them is is okay Steve I just cared about
the pan
and Steve Jobs for the future I was so
gung-ho fighting every product he
introduced I was there I loved him I
loved the products I felt they were good
because they came from Steve Jobs I was
gung ho for them one of them is like the
Macintosh she portrays it like a bunch
of people were for the Apple - and not
the Macintosh when he introduced it you
know what we sat down he showed me the
1984 commercial privately and he said
that the board had voted it down where
it wasn't going to show it's the Super
Bowl and I was shocked and I said part
of the reason was it cost $800,000 for
the spot weekend and I said Steve I'll
pay for in a thousand if you'll pay for
in a thousand and we can show this we
can show this ad because we should show
it because this is us I believed in the
Macintosh so much even John Sculley
believed in the Macintosh it's just that
you have to manage a business and it was
going to take three years to build the
market and Steve didn't understand that
these kind of interactions come out in
the movie but the miss the miss are
sometimes different jobs was good and
they didn't listen to him and messed up
Apple no no that's not true
no no the movie kind of shows a true
part of it but it doesn't really in the
movie is not about reality the movies
about personalities how would a
discussion between Steve and John
Sculley have gone down and they even
show them meaning at a later date Steve
never talked to John Sculley again in
his life so if as you say everything in
the movie didn't happen maybe does it
matter does it matter that this then
becomes the popular understanding of
what did happen well listen to this in
the background of what was going on it
wasn't about what was going on because
everyone knows the story of the
evolution of personal computers of the
evolution of Apple of the evolution of
Apple products everyone knows that this
was in private means that are never on
video ever
how would Steve interact with people on
a daily basis and it shows different
sides of Steve in that regard so you're
saying it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if it didn't happen
it matters said it's a great movie this
movie is a product if Steve Jobs were
making movies as his product this is the
quality that he would have had
absolutely right so let's talk about the
acting which you said was amazing Seth
Rogen's portrayal of you what did you
think I'd like very much the character
that he played even the character doing
things that I didn't do or in very
different places or times or ways I
liked the way he played I looked at
character I admired that character even
though it's
words I could never say negative words
you know Steve you didn't do anything I
could never say a thing like that
and I never would I would say what he
did was more important the way he says
it back to me I would never say Steve
you call him an a-hole you epithet I
would never do that in life I just can't
I'm just - did you ever talk to Seth oh
yes yeah tell me about that uh well he's
just one of the coolest actors in my
mind I'm glad they picked him to portray
me he went on Jimmy Fallon he said I've
never this is unusual role I've not
usually go play people were smarter than
me usually plays a role of somebody
that's so what about Michael Fassbender
his portrayal of jobs what did you think
I saw it and this was like a real person
I saw the Steve Jobs that I loved in a
lot of scenes for the things he was
saying and I saw Steve Jobs as you know
sometimes not caring what other people
think he's going to do things his way
he's right one reality distortion or not
saw all of those and they were actually
very realistic to how Steve Jobs might
have done it but it wasn't how Steve
Jobs acted every minute of every day
like in the movie it had to be convinced
they picked a lot of the most dramatic
scenes you could make out of the
reputation of Steve Jobs
so Tim Cook came out saying he felt this
movie was opportunistic Johnny I've
later said he feels like Steve's image
and likeness have been hijacked that
there are sons and daughters and widows
who are really upset about this movie
what do you what do you make of that
well that those comments actually got to
me really deeply and I started thinking
yeah to make it it's opportunistic on
someone's life but every business
everything any business does is
opportunistic but this is kind of taking
a person's reputation
the thing is Steve Jobs has multiple
sides to his personality that he's known
for known for a lot of greatness and
thinking ahead are great products really
look at look at the iPod in the iPhone
that was sort of the start of it how
music is sold but these movies all go
back to a former part of time that isn't
up to that point in time when those
things happened so it talks about a lot
of and they're just hundreds of cases
that I know firsthand experiences some
of them even with meat were Steve did
things how could any human being do this
you sit there so there are a lot of
those in his past and unfortunately
legacy has to live with the truth or not
so Laurene Powell Jobs as we understand
it called a couple of actors to try to
get them to not
participate in the film did she ever
call you and say well be part of this
well she probably got the script if she
was able to call them and I can
absolutely you know I feel I feel 2
sides of me I feel very bad about you
know this is going to give Steve Jobs
some more emphasis on some one kind of
like one bad thing he did in his life so
did you talk to Laura nor did she try to
reach out to you no I don't I'm not
really close to them okay and but now if
it sort of stunned me to read that and I
had to start rethinking a little you
know a little bit and it is
opportunistic on a person's life but
look at this I'm in the movie as a
little bit of a bad person toward Steve
calling him names things I would never
do and I'm looking bad so it makes me
look bad but no no it's so well played
enacted the artistic element by the way
it did um for most of the products there
were three product introductions in this
movie and basically some of these people
like Tim Cook weren't around Steve Jobs
during that timeframe how do you think
of a job Tim Cook is doing today I love
it I love the open the the greater
consideration for charitable needs
worrying about the employees and
treating them all equally and fairly and
the products that are coming out are not
hedging back edging back and staying out
of you know what they should all be
saying I love in terms of the products
what do you think of the state of
innovation at Apple the state of
innovation is is high but people think
of innovation is brand new categories of
products something like a car who knows
if there's going to be an Apple car but
things like phones you kind of reach a
point where things plateau and they get
good and sometimes the best thing is
make sure every product works as well as
the other one for anybody and doesn't
confuse them and lose them something
Steve Jobs was very good at in other
words put in the balance of the best of
the best of features and you don't have
to be the top camera in the world the
highest speed processor in the world the
longest battery life in the world you
just have to be good very good in every
category a good balance but you like
your Apple watch yeah like it for a lot
of things what do you think of the Apple
watch um I think it's good it's
convenient uh if I forget my watch am I
going to be stuck no because I always
have to have the phone anyway
and sometimes I pull out the phone and
sometimes I try things on the watching
sends me into the phone but but for the
most part the things when the watch
works I'll ask a question you know you
know hey Siri where am I
what city am I in I'll get at me I'll
get answers or what's the tallest
mountain in Argentina and I'll get the
answer so how optimistic are you about
the prospect of an Apple car I'm
extremely optimistic because um just the
name Apple I'm in that group too
although I don't treat it like it's a
holy religion and there's one one icon
um no but Apple has to do something
how's it coming like Apple the largest
company in the world to grow it has to
be something very huge financially and
cars are about to go through huge
financial turnover if we get to electric
cars self-driving cars charging stations
you think Apple can do it as well as for
example your accidents less less less
medical money right do you think Apple
can do it as well as Tesla for example
um you know it's hard to say Apple can
do it yeah better course I'm not gonna
say no I don't think Apple can I'm not
going to say that that'd be stupid any
company out there General Motors could
possibly do it better than Tesla but
Tesla I admire so much it's like I
almost think nobody can do it better
they could do it equal
do you miss Steve do you still miss
Steve um I I miss him but again you know
it was such a strong idle ISM and this
and that and I'm not a religious type
person in a cult type person you know we
have one cult leader so I don't so that
part I don't miss are there any who are
the innovators out there that you think
embody some of his qualities well I I
actually admire Elon Musk because the
nature of his car his car like Steve
Jobs built an iPhone and talked about
how every little detail had to be right
for him and that iPhone came out not
crowded not cluttered it was just a
beautiful transformation Elon built a
car for himself the Model S Tesla and it
has taken over the world we got the
first cart successful car startup
company in America since 1927 have you
ever been asked to take a role on
Apple's board or a ceremonial position
with Apple would you like to be more
involved in the day-to-day there I've
ever been asked Steve Jobs has asking me
questions along those lines near the
time he was dying which
did you want to come back to Apple and I
thought no no I love the life I have I
have a really nice life I get to go
around talk to high schoolers and
university students and and governments
and you know inspire them to want to
have creation of technology and make
that a part of their business what did
he want you to do at Apple what he
didn't say anything he was just sort of
asked him like he had read some did you
really want to come back who knows maybe
some little role but you know what I
told them I come frankly I'm sorry
running big companies the organization
the the personal ethics versus the
business ethics I couldn't really do it
I'm not the right person for that